hi I'd like to talk to you today about
inheritance as a fundamental concept in
object-oriented programming
it's use in Python and also tips and
tricks for using inheritance in Python
in object-oriented programming in the
object-oriented programming paradigm in
601 first thing I'm going to do is give
a really quick crash course on
inheritance to catch up to speed and
also so that you're clear on you know
what I mean when I say something like
parent class and also I'm going to
address the sort of little nuances of
using inheritance while programming in
an object or even in Python a lot of the
code in 601 is object it uses the
object-oriented programming paradigm and
a lot of the code in 601 will inherit
from parent classes so you know it's
part of the motivation for you know
going through a quick review and then
also indicating the most common slip-ups
and also are the most significant things
that you may or may not have seen from
other languages alright first let's talk
about let's you know crash course on
inheritance let's look at the board
inheritance is the idea that you can
arrange objects in a hierarchical
fashion such that very very generalized
or basic things that are true of a whole
group of objects can be specified at a
higher level and then you can work your
way down to progressively more specific
levels the most the most formal
encounter you've probably had with this
thing is that that approach is the
biological taxonomy right kingdom phylum
class order family genus species every
species has all the properties of that
particular genus all the all the genus
is of a particular family have the
properties of that family and so on and
so forth that's a very concrete example
but I find it a little boring so I'm
going to talk about dog race instead
you're probably familiar with the fact
that golden retrievers our type of
retriever and that retrievers are a
different are a particular kind of dog
you can make generalizations about
Golden's based on what you know about
dogs right like all dogs bark all dogs
have four legs if they you know aren't
injured or have some sort of congenital
defects that kind of thing
and Golden's also have all the
properties of retrievers right they are
capable of going and catching game that
you've either shot or possibly like
chase it down and bring it back to you
so they're bred to have you know very
particular properties Golden's are also
bred to have very particular properties
and those that are very specific to
Golden's are the define the difference
between a golden versus a retrieve from
the general sense likewise when we want
to make objects that have very
particular properties but also share
general properties with other objects
we're going to create a new category of
object and put those just put the
specifics in that very specific category
and then take the things that we can
generalize and put them in more general
categories so we don't end up rewriting
a lot of code or we end up reusing code
but not copying and pasting it
everywhere because that's annoying the
other major advantage of using
inheritance is that code is more
intuitive you can you could make
references to the same piece of code all
over the place but it's not as it's not
as intuitive ly accessible to to you
know do that over and over and over
again right it's really convenient to
think of the fact that golden could be a
subclass or subtype of Retriever and
that retriever could be a subclass or
subtype of dog when I talk about when I
talk about this relationship in terms of
object oriented programming my topic
about when I talk about these categories
in terms of object oriented programming
and when you're actually looking at code
Golden's are a subclass or child class
of retrievers and retrievers
are a parent class or superclass
Golden's likewise dogs are apparent
class of retrievers so now I've defined
my terminology and also hopefully given
you a very very very quick review of
inheritance now I'm going to talk about
the specifics in Python if I turn over
here I've written up a very short class
definition for a dog right every dog has
the class attribute cry every dog has an
initialization method that gives every
dog a very specific name that is passed
in when you initialize the dog and every
dog has access to the class method
greeting which returns a string that
says I'm whatever the name of the dog is
and also the specific cry which in this
case is actually the class cry if you're
unfamiliar with using the plus in terms
of strings it's just a concatenate er so
you know play around that with that in
idle if you're confused I would
recommend copying all of this into idle
and then playing around with a
particular instantiation of dogs in this
case Lassie if you look at lassie name
you'll end up going after self dot name
which is specified when you initialize
the object so lessees name is lassie
likewise if you were to actually if you
were to type in lassie greeting open
paren close paren and hit enter you
should forget a string return that says
I'm Lassie comma bark mostly this is to
familiarize you with the object-oriented
programming a Python in the general
sense now we're going to look at what
happens when you want to set up a
subclass if I set up class Retriever and
I want to inherit from the superclass
dog I'm going to pass in dog this in the
same syntax that I would use if it were
a function and I wanted to pass in a
parameter if I wanted to inherit from
multiple things or multiple classes I
would put multiple classes here right
now we're just going to inherit from dog
note that I have no code here this is
this is pretty much meant to explicitly
specify the fact that Retriever is not
actually going to introduce any new
properties to dogs their types are going
to be different so if I create something
that's a retriever it will be of object
type Retriever versus if I create
something and say dog open paren close
paren it's going to be of type dog but
what happens when I create a retriever
and as an aside if you know who Benji is
I know he's not a retriever but you know
bear with me here if I create a
retriever it's first going to look for
an initialization and any other methods
or attributes in the Retriever class
definition run any code that's here and
then go to the parent class and run all
the code here so even though retriever
did not have any explicit code
underneath it I can still interact with
the object Benji the same way that I
interacted with the object Lassie
it has all the same methods and all the
same attributes so there's basic
inheritance and I will make it another
aside that if you're doing this you
probably don't need to create a subclass
in the first place this is you know if
you're designing your own code and
you're trying to think about what the
best way to organize things is if you
have to create a sub type or a subclass
and there are no new methods or
attributes or no different ways of
addressing those methods or attributes
then this category is probably actually
just this category you may want to make
a difference so that you can do
interesting things with type checking I
think that's the only thing I can think
of that would justify it and I might be
wrong
you know Python gurus out there should
correct me but a thing to keep in mind
so we've done the first half of our
inheritance we're gonna inherit one more
time and create a class for golden
retrievers once again
I've got my class definition and my
indication that I'm going to hear it
from retriever I don't have any
initialization or attribute assignments
I only have a definition for greeting so
what happens here well the first thing
we always do is look for in an
initialization method golden doesn't
have one so it's gonna check the
retriever class retriever doesn't have
one so it's gonna check the dog class
the initialization method is here so
when it when it runs the initialization
method it's going to run this code
the first thing that's going to happen
is any any code for any attribute
assignments or method definitions here
are going to be considered the Canon or
you know the the first thing that any
golden is going to reference so greeting
is going to be executed before greeting
used in any other place you notice the
only difference between this greeting
and the dog greeting is that
ohai has been prepended to the phrase
and the way that we end up doing that is
we refer to we concatenate and then
refer to the superclass and once again
we have to pass in the explicit argument
self when we're talking about a class
definition later when you actually
instantiate an object and you know user
friends you're not going to have to put
self as an argument it'll get confused
we'll go over that in a second so let's
say I create a golden retriever Sydney
I'm gonna pass in one argument which is
the name we're going to consider all the
definitions here first which means that
Golden's are going to have a method for
greeting that is specified here it's
going to use the method for greeting
from retriever and we could we could put
in anything here right we could put dog
dog greeting we could put in like some
other function that is in the same
environment as class golden but here we
can explicitly access the superclass
that we defined here
we're gonna head over to retriever to
see if there are any additional methods
or attributes that are a consequence of
being a subclass of retriever that we
need to add to our definition and we
just hit the pass on the other hand
retriever inherits from dog so once
again we have to jump over to a
superclass and grab any attributes or
methods that are defined there as well
so all the way back over to Sydney when
I call Sydney greeting the first thing
that happens is that I look in the most
specific subclass or whatever my object
type is and see if there's a definition
for the method because there is I'm not
going to use dog doc reading I'm gonna
use golden doc reading golden doc
reading says return a string that says
oh hi and also append it to whatever
Retriever greeting returns I go over to
retriever it's not here but I still have
a reference to dog I go over to dog it
has a method for greeting and it says
I'm Sydney mark so the final return type
should be oh hi I'm Sydney
this concludes my basic overview of
inheritance with inheritance of
object-oriented on 4 601 next time I'll
review some interesting features and
pythons that are actually from
originated in earlier languages and also
particular things in aliasing that
people that are new to Python or people
that are new to programming find
especially confusing